this right here is a picture of renee
descartes once again one of the great
minds in both math and philosophy and i
think you'll you're seeing a little bit
of a trend here that the great
philosophers were also great
mathematicians and vice versa and he was
somewhat of a contemporary of galileo he
was 32 years younger although he died he
died shortly after galileo died this guy
died much at a much younger age galileo
was well into his 70s descartes died at
what this is only at 54 years old and
he's probably most known in popular
culture for this quote right over here a
very philosophical quote i think
therefore i am but i also wanted to
throw in and this isn't that related to
algebra but i just thought it was a
really neat quote probably his least
famous quote this one right over here
and i like it just because it's very
practical it makes you realize that
these great minds these pillars of
philosophy and mathematics at the end of
the day they really were just human
beings and he said you just keep pushing
you just keep pushing i made every
mistake that could be made but i just
kept pushing which i think is very very
good life advice
now he did many things in philosophy and
mathematics but the reason why i'm
including here as we build our
foundations of algebra is that he is the
individual most responsible for a very
strong connection between algebra and
geometry
so on the left over here you have the
world of algebra and we've discussed it
a little bit you have equations that
deal with symbols and these symbols are
essentially they can take on values so
you could have something like y is equal
to 2x
y is equal to 2x minus 1. this gives us
a relationship between whatever x is and
whatever y is and we can even set up a
table here
and pick values for x and see what the
values of y would be and i could just
pick random valid
random values for x and then figure out
what y is but i'll pick relatively
straightforward values
just so that the math doesn't get too
complicated so for example if x is
negative 2 then y is going to be 2 times
negative 2 minus 1
2 times negative 2
minus 1 which is negative 4 negative 4
minus 1 which is negative 5.
if x is negative 1 then y is going to be
2 times negative 1
2 times negative 1 minus 1
which is equal to this is negative 2
minus 1 which is negative 3.
if x is equal to
0
x is equal to 0 then y is going to be 2
times 0 minus 1. 2 times 0 0 minus 1 is
just negative 1. i'll do a couple more
if x is one and i could have picked any
values here i could have said well what
happens if x is the negative square root
of two or what happens if x is negative
five halves or positive positive six
sevens but i'm just picking these
numbers because it makes the math a lot
easier when i try to figure out what y
is going to be but when x is 1 y is
going to be 2 times 1 minus 1. 2 times 1
is 2 minus 1 is 1. and i'll do one more
i'll do one more in a color that i have
not used yet let's see this purple
if x is two then y is going to be two
times
two now our x is two minus one
minus one so that is four minus one is
equal to three so fair enough i just
kind of sampled this relationship i said
okay this describes a general
relationship between a variable y and a
variable x and then i just made a little
bit more concrete i said okay well then
if x is one of these variable for each
of these values of x what would be the
corresponding value of y
and what descartes realized is is that
you could visualize this one you could
visualize these individual points
but that could also help you in general
to visualize this relationship and so
what he essentially did is he bridged
the worlds of this kind of very abstract
symbolic algebra and that and geometry
which was concerned with shapes and
sizes and angles so over here you have
the world of you have the world of
geometry
and obviously there are people in
history maybe many people who history
may have forgotten who might have
dabbled in this but before descartes
it's generally viewed that geometry was
euclidean geometry and that's
essentially the geometry that you study
in a geometry class in in eighth or
ninth grade or tenth grade
in a traditional high school curriculum
and that's the geometry of studying the
relationships between triangles and
their angles and the relationships
between circles and you have radii and
and then you have triangles inscribed in
circles and all the rest and we go into
some depth in that in the geometry
playlist but descartes says well i think
i can represent this visually the same
way that euclid was studying these
triangles and these circles he said well
why don't i if we view a if we view a
piece of paper if we if we think about a
two-dimensional plane you could view a
piece of paper as kind of a section of a
two-dimensional plane
we call it two dimensions because
there's two directions that you could go
in there's the up down direction that's
one direction so let me draw that i'll
do it in blue because we're trying to do
we're trying to visualize things so i'm
doing the geometry color so you have the
up down direction you have the up down
direction and you have the left right
direction
that's why it's called a two-dimensional
plane if we're dealing in three
dimensions you would have an in-out
dimension
in out and it's very easy to do two
dimensions on the screen because the
screen is two-dimensional and he says
well you know there are two variables
here and they have this relationship so
why don't i associate each of these
variables with one of these dimensions
over here
and by convention let's make
the y variable which is really the
dependent variable the way we did it it
depends on what x is let's put that on
the vertical axis and let's put our
independent variable the one where i
just randomly picked values for it to
see what y would become let's put that
on the horizontal axis and it actually
was descartes who came up with the
convention of using x's and y's and
we'll see later z's in algebra so
extensively as unknown variables or the
variables that you're manipulating but
he says well if we think about it this
way if we number if we number these
these these dimensions so let's say that
in the x direction let's make this right
over here this right over here is
negative
three
let's make this negative two this is
negative one this is zero now we're just
i'm just number numbering the x
direction the left right direction now
this is positive one this is positive
two and this is positive three
and we can do the same in the y
direction so let's see we go so this
could be let's say this is negative 5
negative 4
negative 3 negative actually let me do
it a little bit neater than that
let me clean this up a little bit
so let me erase this and extend this
down a little bit so i can go all the
way down to negative five without making
it look too messy
so let's go all the way down here and so
we can number it this is one this is two
this is three and then this could be
negative one
negative two and these are all just
conventions it could have been labeled
the other way we could have decided to
put the x there and the y there and make
this the positive direction make this
the negative direction but this is just
the convention that people adopted
starting with descartes negative 2
negative 3
negative 4 and negative 5.
and he says well i think i can associate
i can associate each of these pairs of
values with a point on in two dimensions
i can take the x coordinate i can take
the x value right over here and i say
okay that's negative 2 that would be
right over there on along the left right
direction i'm going to the left because
it's negative and that's associated with
negative 5 in the vertical direction so
i say the y value is negative 5 and so
if i go 2 to the left two to the left
and five down and five down i get to
this point right over there so he says
the this these two values negative two
negative five i can associate it with
this point in the core in this plane
right over here in this two-dimensional
plane so i'll say that point
is has the coordinates tells me where to
find that point negative two
negative five and these coordinates are
called cartesian coordinates named for
rene descartes he's the guy that came up
with these he's associating all of a
sudden these relationships with points
on a coordinate plane and then he says
well okay let's do another one there's
this other relationship where i have
when x is equal to negative 1
when x is equal to negative 1 y is equal
to negative 3. so x is negative 1 y is
negative 3. that's that point right over
there and the convention is once again
when you list the coordinates you list
the x coordinate then the y coordinate
and that's just what people decided to
do
negative 1 negative 3 that would be that
point right over there and then you have
the point when x is 0 y is negative 1.
when x is 0 right over here which means
i don't go to the left or the right y is
negative 1 which means i go 1 down so
that's that point right over there 0
negative 1
right over there and i could keep doing
this
when x is 1 y is 1. when x is 1 y
is 1. when x is 2 y is 3.
when x is 2 y is 3. actually let me do
that same purple color
when x is 2 y
is 3. 2 comma 3 and then this one right
over here in orange was 1 comma 1. and
this is neat by itself i essentially
just sampled possible x's but what he
realized is not only do you sample these
possible x's but if you just kept
sampling x's if you tried sampling all
the x's in between you would actually
end up plotting out a line
so if you were to do every possible x
you would end up getting a line that
looks something like
a line that looks something like that
right over there
and any any relation if you pick any x
and and find any y it really represents
a point on this line or another way to
think about it any point on this line
represents a solution to this equation
right over here so if you have this
point right over here which looks like
it's about x is one and a half y is two
so let me write that one 1.5
1.5 comma 2. that is a solution to this
equation when x is 1.5 2 times 1.5 is 3
minus 1 is 2. that is right over there
so all of a sudden he was able to bridge
this gap or or this this this
relationship between algebra and
geometry
we can now visualize
all of the all of the x and y pairs that
satisfy this this equation right over
here and so he is responsible he is
responsible for making this bridge and
that's why the coordinates that we use
to specify these points are called
cartesian coordinates and as we'll see
the first type of equations we will
study are equations of this form over
here and in a traditional algebra
curriculum they're called linear
equations
linear
equations and you might be saying well
you know okay this is an equation i see
that this is equal to that but what's so
linear about them what what makes them
look like a line and to realize why they
are linear you have to make this jump
that rene descartes made
because if you were to plot this using
cartesian coordinates on a euclidean
plane you will get a line and in the
future we'll see that there's other
types of equations where you won't get a
line well you'll get a curve or
something something kind of crazy or
funky